[Music]
we should i would like an orchestral uh
like a
children's choir version not children's
you know what's funny is i realize most
of our clips are about pedophilia
most of the clips i put up on instagram
are like you see these little girls
right so i'm gonna try to give it a rest
i just you want a kid's pop version i
think
i don't want to k i want like a oh i
want like uh
it's a sad movie it's an action movie
the like the peanuts christmas song yes
yes they just and like the joker they
did they did the
um they did the uh
kurt cobain whatever his band was called
um
hi uh be hello let's we'll get into it
uh we got some songs from
so we used to have the the scratch with
the
how you feel nail but it felt it felt a
little jack johnson
sorry which one on the podcast it would
be like wiggy wiggy how you feeling i
don't like the wig
yeah i don't i don't it just felt too
jack johnson
it felt like it just felt like something
about it just
didn't i don't like the scratching okay
as we all know my
my gift is to be
not well of course is to be
hip-hop adjacent without trying to do
to do it and speak the king's english
and still
have relationships with the black people
okay eric johnson the great eric johnson
of course
sent us broke us off some transition
songs
i have one that i prefer but let's see
what you think
what one more time
you're not gonna hear it that's what it
is okay
all right go to the next one next on the
dock
[Music]
that one's cool the background's too
loud he overdid it
that one's pretty good i like whatever
on that's good moving on to my favorite
okay
what else is happening is too much we
know that they're starting to turn
moving on starting to turn into when you
get a
you get a computer program like back in
the day but it's like
they're also like a casio what i got
uh they're too similar
in the wrong way like the good ones are
good but they're like
well we just need to pick one and we're
picking moving on
great beautiful it's got a 70s feel
yeah baby come back
all right great let's move on do you
hear about brianna taylor
hear about this brianna taylor well of
course uh
[Music]
okay i was a little i thought it was
insensitive and then there are
roaches in the they're roach
termites well they made a roaches
i do feel like when i see a cop car i
have the same reaction when i see a
cockroach not like to completely insult
cops but just kind of like
ah [ __ ] yeah i did it
when i was driving like when i drive
yeah not when i see
a cop it just feels like [ __ ] i'm not do
i do
i i i'm white and i'm
very rarely glad to see a cop yeah and
there's a
and i'm like the i'm their guy you know
what i mean like you're fine
i'm [ __ ] but i don't even like i
don't like being watched anyway
unless i control it guys go on
youtube.com we've got
uh if you don't like this setup in terms
of cameras
we can't help you because ken just left
ken sang the dp and it took
two hours and he brought a guy so
um the okay so
the cop one cop got like some ticky tack
charge
yeah well they all got fired i think
right i don't
i don't know i think they're all fired
but no charges brought against them so
then the one guy
got the one guy one guy just got charges
for
wanton it
it was a wonton shooting and so it just
basically
they're only charging the bullet for the
bullets that hit the neighbors
the neighbor's apartment which is
basically like
it's like a vandalism charge yeah you
know
uh you oh man reckless
uh the neighbors were white i don't know
if that matters
that always matters uh
the somebody asked if ken asked what we
thought
and if we blame the cops i or did we
blame the system
i'm gonna go a hundred percent system
65 percent cops fully agree uh
because it the system the fact that
there's no knock warrants
apparently they're not there aren't any
more they finally canceled them
um in in louisville
or anywhere kentucky yeah why are there
no knock warrants anywhere
there are theories that okay well drug
um people selling drugs they have
cameras
so we just will like basically we'll
ambush them so they can't get rid of
evidence stuff but the risk reward seems
so
it's it because the origin the origins
of all this
is war on drugs like you were saying
before off yes it's all war on drugs
and it's not they didn't have cameras
they weren't how badly do you
want like do you want to endanger
everybody
for the for the one preserve
drug evidence i mean i just i don't know
if it's like some
large rico case or some international
[ __ ] that's one thing
but even when you read it it's like tens
of thousands of dollars of like drugs
and money and
in the average no knock or just even in
this case it's not a lot of money
right but this case her ex-boyfriend
who's already locked up
so he's in custody she and i guess she
got something mailed there or
he got something mailed there to her
house he was a drug he just sold drugs
he
used her address to ship drugs through
the postal service okay
at some point yeah but he's been in and
out of jail i mean whatever it's like
it's not so much like uh he's a
innocent character and they're framing
him no he's no i believe that the guy
sold drugs like that checks out but why
a year
he's been locked up they haven't been
together for
a couple a year or two the problem is
that
they i think they they towed his car
and on his bank statements
um it's her address
but the problem the thing is there's
just little things there's little things
that the police leaked
to say like see this is why we went but
regardless of
all of it it doesn't when you look at
even the most damning
stuff you know like i looked at the
report the worst of the worst
doesn't justify any of it doesn't
justify the no knock warrant they knew
he didn't live there
they knew all these things you know they
just wanted to go collect
evidence i guess that was kind of the
point didn't they already have a case
against him though
they already had a case against why how
much more evidence do they want like and
you know he had a car right
we'll have you know you know this man
had a car when he would drive around
right the point is what is worth
someone's life is it worth
all of this nonsense to collect evidence
that may be still
at this place of previous place of
revenue of residence
yes i don't know is it worth it it seems
not worth it at all and
i just something about it just seems so
we're making this case brianna taylor's
cases obviously
we're talking about it and blah blah but
it just feels like this has happened a
million times
this is nothing new yes it's the
it's the law the so that's the the laws
are [ __ ] stupid
and where i blame the cops is
working in a corrupt system happily
or without
whether they're happy or not they
certainly aren't looking to do anything
about it no no one's like we got us yeah
like this
this is unfair to everyone there's none
of that
and you're not gonna believe this
they forgot to turn on their cameras no
they have them did you see the video
footage that was leaked
no they i i just read the new yorker
that they had
footage from when the backup
cops came the vice footage that leaked
is
when after the shooting so their policy
is that if you're involved in a shooting
you can't be at the crime scene
while people come to investigate
everything right so
the footage shows all
the footage shows all i was laughing at
neil doing something this isn't funny at
all
don't worry it's not for audio i don't i
do all visual comedy now okay
i just drank something it was funny it
was pretty funny uh
so they're all there the guys who shot
brianna taylor and the two other cops
they should have been gone they should
have been gone and they were like oh is
this
is this are these shrapnels ours or his
now those look like ours oh
we should wait is anybody like i think
one of the cops walks in
to the apartments like anybody dead in
here
yeah i don't i can't tell if that was a
joke
uh well it certainly wasn't protocol
it just seems like this is what happens
when no one's saying
brianna's ex is some amazing guy
but you shouldn't have to be completely
innocent
to to get justice in this country that's
the weirdest thing especially if she was
completely innocent she's completely
innocent
yeah so i just feel like people on like
so you can't even
know a criminal now without getting
without your life
the the uh your odds of living reduced
greatly
um and this is one of these things where
she probably didn't know what address he
put down
no he kept giving her number
as his number sometimes yeah because
he's a [ __ ] dirtbag criminal that's
what those guys do
like i again that's again not on her
none of this is on her she should be
alive and no knock warrants are weird
and it's just it goes into this police
um culture of us versus them cops like
cops and robbers like get
like now it's like no these are people
and the other thing that people forget
about cops a lot
is their [ __ ] meatheads
they're dumb meathead
giant [ __ ] fat headed
bad haircut having no sideburn
rocking bad hair bad facial hair
[ __ ]
they're not smart and then they get
hopped up yeah before these situations
they they act like it's a [ __ ] under
armour commercial
and they're a high school football team
they're like
and so they want to shoot people they do
yeah they hear a gun first of all they
didn't announce themselves so
they're right there so right there
what if this is against the law what you
did is against the law they got
12 they asked 12 neighbors if they
announced themselves
12 said no they got the 13th neighbor to
say
yes after repeating the question
multiple times so they coerced that
they didn't have their cameras turned on
and
if you're not doing anything wrong
don't turn your camera off
okay so what they're they're basically
saying
uh we're because you might have cameras
we need no knock warrants yeah you
because you
so i'm gonna start doing no knock
warrants at police precincts
because clearly these [ __ ] maniacs
don't understand that's
that what's good for the goose is good
for the game i know an old man um
that's a old man phrase if i've ever
heard it um
but then so if now it's essentially that
the cops
are they're just unchecked for so long
who checks the cops i think if you and
that
that d.a who's just like a
classic i have so many words yeah i
don't i
i have this is there are times where i
wish i were black so i could say certain
things
but you you know what i think you know
what part of the plantation he lives in
stop if we're talking about plantation
stuff
he's not in the field i'll say that he
is he is no longer in
the field he is can i say that as a
white person what if i were going to
predict what part of the plantation
a person would work in um i think only
to
uh hated black people no one's going to
take a stand against it
wouldn't i say that to candace owens i
was like yeah whatever yeah how how
but i don't i don't you maybe don't get
too liberal with me he's just a field
placement he's a houseworker
he's more he's closer to the to the he's
close
he's managerial estate manager yeah he's
an estate manager that's right um
no there's something so but that's the
same with jackie lacy it's the same with
kamala harris when she was the da for
california i mean
they're do we think this one black guy
is gonna
rise up well yes and yeah there's no one
there's not like white because he
wouldn't
die yeah that's exactly right
and does he you're dealing with lunk
heads
a and you're dealing with the most
self-pitying lunkheads as we've
discussed multiple times
and so they'll do the thing that they do
de blasio where they turn their back on
him
when he enters the room and he very
much works in tandem with them so you
want cops to you want to have a
relationship with cops
if you're the d.a you want to believe
them yeah
but the problem is what
i just don't understand why hey if this
is the protocol and this is the policy
when you break it and we can't prove
what happened because your body cam is
off
then you should be immediately
liable they by the way
the people that people in the state of
kentucky have to pay 12 million dollars
i'm assuming that's the state
or it's probably the municipal insurance
um
yes somehow they're they're they'll pay
a portion of the good people are paying
for it
it's just not surprising at all oh it's
surprising that's surprising
fact that i'm surprised they even got 12
million dollars like that's surprising
that that is the most surprising i don't
get how
killing someone is not
you you're not indicting them on that
but you're indicting
an officer based on not killing
the neighbor like almost killing the
neighbor like i don't did you read why
that was
yeah i didn't get into the weeds on it
uh
the yes because
once the per once the gun go once the
boy
the new boyfriend's gun uh goes off
um now everybody then it's all
all every man for himself uh
but it's an apartment building so
you kind of got to be mindful of there
was just a lot of
like reading the new york article there
was just a lot of [ __ ] that
her sister lived there they didn't know
she had a sister
they didn't know she lived there yeah
they didn't plan they didn't do like a
layout
they're just it's just a bunch of lunk
heads running through a banner at the
beginning of a football game yeah
that's what every that's his address go
there
and then they all run through the banner
but meanwhile
it's like those videos where someone's
standing in front of the banner and then
the they get knocked over
it doesn't break like you got no they it
breaks but there's like a little kid who
lost a frisbee from what happens to me
so you've got to be my
if you're gonna do an invasion
yeah get some schematics you [ __ ]
dummies yeah you [ __ ] lunk heads
and then it's a lot of covering up like
apparently like the ballistics fbi came
in and did their
own investigation and their ballistics
say that the boyfriend
new boyfriend did not shoot first and so
it's just all this
that's the other thing did i uh
i don't know if he's somebody did a joke
where he said he was talking to a member
of lapd
and the lapd guy said the guy had a
stalker
oh yeah it's yeah i don't know if he
doesn't he does a whole bit on it
right i don't know if he's done it on
television yet but that's like years ago
yeah dane did a bit about yeah that
vid's crazy that bit's [ __ ] great
a but it was about he had
dane hook had a stalker and he had a
[ __ ] really good bit which was like
he was like stalker now i get 10 years
ago why are you stalking me now which is
[ __ ] funny
i always said dane was funny um and
uh he talked to an lapd guy who said
get a gun get a shotgun yeah um
she steps onto your property
blaster um after you've blasted her
fire another shot into the ceiling you
will then
afterwards say that the that was your
warning shot
lapd told them that yeah so
uh that's what you're dealing with where
the cops are not gonna [ __ ] tell that
they don't
telling the truth makes you an outlier
yeah in the in
in from what i can tell in the police
force so
it's just wrong it's just
everything about it's wrong yeah and
it is a uh
it's just a tragedy it's just a [ __ ]
tragedy
um barkley charles barkley got in
trouble
for because he said okay
does car charles berkeley always he's
always giving like
what is it in the supreme court the
dissent like he's always
he's always like well but he's not like
a nosy
[ __ ] about it he's like look let me do
his reading
okay first of all we do have to take
into account that her boyfriend did
shoot at the cop
and shot a cop so like i said even
though i'm really sorry she lost her
life
this is going to seem like i'm doing it
yeah i'm doing a blessing and doing
barkley just do it do neil that's not as
much fun i do a good barkley i'm getting
i'm choking up
i'm choking you guys get out of here you
can stop listening
first of all that's a good barkley uh i
don't think we can just say that uh
we can put this in the same situation
with george floyd in a mont aubry
i just don't believe that okay
so then and then there was lots of um
but
like okay we go sorry he kneeled it
doesn't need to be said no he kneeled it
he kneeled it but does it need to be
said no but does he believe it yes does
it
does it um
does he i actually didn't know the
boyfriend shot
so when i saw that i was like oh that's
interesting so then i looked up
i i kind of didn't know i just thought
it was like cops
they they just started blasting no they
shot but they had like some like of the
60 or 20 i [ __ ] 30. i don't know how
many shots were
shot total but yeah yeah it was majority
there's three versus one guy but um
he they he just heard a battering ram
like he just heard someone kicked in his
door
yeah no it wants you it's not like they
started they were
i've had you know drunk people try to
open my front door yeah
first of all keith's a nice guy
don't he doesn't keith my dog keith does
not play that [ __ ] really it's one of
those things where he'll go
he'll get [ __ ] furious when someone
tries to open the door and then it's the
thing where 10 minutes later he's still
on some like
yeah he's like i'm not over here dude
keith's that drunk guy at the bar that
like can't let you go
he'll play there's a couple things he
does not play and that's one of them
scuffing up his stacey adams yeah
um
keep saying literally and i gotta be
telling you is listening to you do that
right now like
yeah like what's he talk oh yeah he's
time when people try to come in the
middle of the night
so
you can't get mad at the boyfriend for
what should he have done
it sounded like someone was yes it's if
you're undercover and you don't say who
you are i'm not going to be like
oh come on in what do you can i help you
guys with
right with your battering ram you guys
must be from ubereats
what with your bat you just that might
be yeah you can just leave it out in
front guys next time i'll put it in the
contactless delivery yes i'll put it in
the in the comments
neil likes to say uh bring me my sauce
your tip depends on it bring me my sauce
yes your tip depends
my favorite story by the way it's the
best it's so funny because
bro we don't play it's a story i think
it's one of the first episodes or maybe
it was before we did the podcast it was
way more i wrote
i got delivery
from sequoia a place i really like in
l.a it's
like it's it's uh it's mexican it's like
not shitty it's a lot of vegetables it's
organic
and it's a lot of uh vegan [ __ ] and i
wrote
extra vegan crema which is cream
it's spanish for cream and uh you idiot
you uncultured idiot that's spanish for
cream
and uh and i wrote something your tip
depends on it
it's because the last few times they
delivered it they never you said
exercise and they didn't do yes so i
said your tip depends on it so when he
came
so when the guy came to the door
he brings it he's like hey you know what
you wrote here
nah that's no good
so the guy kind of berated me like not
cool and it's like
sorry for saying out loud that's what
pulling a neil is
yeah i nailed it you know i kneel that
you say
i would argue that's not you needed to
do that to get
what you wanted their attention yes
but i didn't need but i didn't need to
say it i could have said it
the tone neil the tonal neil
um is is a different guy
now he handles it a totally different
way yeah but back then
i thought let's let's get let's take the
ball by the horns
and just let's approach this directly
they weren't having it but it's like no
tips are extortion the whole thing is
just extortion it's just
it's i'm i'm just blackmailing you with
money
to do what i to do a better job
but i didn't see it as extortion i mean
it's just
it's it's an understanding it's it's
it's
agreed to distortion it's flying do you
want more leg room
you're not pay for it if you want to sit
in the back and
just get to where you're going go fine
like but don't expect but it's not
i don't think it's i think flying is not
the right analogy because it's
subtler than that flying you have to pay
extra
to get extra an extra side of beans or
whatever well if you're in the right
setting it's implied that like hey we
tip here yeah of course you can just not
tip everything but the point of tipping
is
yeah it's like yeah there's an agree
there's an understanding i'm going to
give you a good service and you're going
to give me and you're good
right we don't but it's tip it's like
flying if you go to europe or anywhere
else in the [ __ ] world except for
asia
they're happy but everywhere else is
like
[ __ ] you i'm getting paid a livable wage
i don't need your tip and it's not nice
it isn't well the whole the system is
give me
give me good service or the tip gets it
basically i'm holding i'm literally
holding the money hostage yeah you're
right
so what do you want to do extra vegan
crema
that's i just said it i shouldn't have
said it i guess
but i but god forbid me that's what me
and sure that's what makes me and
charles barkley two of the top
broadcasters in the country this is the
problem with charles barkley every time
there's something controversial
a few like a week later there's a
[ __ ] charles
that's what's great about him like he
doesn't know
any better i know but is it and he has a
unique
he just has a very unique experience
sorry when he was doing weight watchers
and then on the mic was like it's
fake and was like i meant
it was easy money like you're
bullshitter
he said what was fake so he was the
suppose this was a different thing
this is he was a vote for weight
watchers and then he was caught on the
hot mic and they're like oh so that wait
to watch the thing he was like
he's like yeah she's like it's [ __ ]
and then
when it came out he was like i was
saying it's it's such easy money that's
how [ __ ] it is like i can't believe
how easy the money is
and after that i'm like you're a
bullshitter like i get it we can all i'm
not saying now he
cannot make a statement speaking of easy
money tough to needle matters
don't have a don't have a code just go
there and get yourself a mattress
it's like we're all [ __ ] so like
don't peddle you
he but he really he has a very unique
experience which is
poor in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
and basically escaped via his talent
moved to philly was always like out of
the he was never he talked about a guy
that just was never
fit the type like he was too fat to be
good at basketball he figured that out
and he doesn't i don't think he anything
he says is premeditated
he you know he it's that he really it's
like where i we were talking about him a
couple weeks ago where he said he never
brings up race when he's insulting
somebody which
i believe him he just has a weird
he's you know but then he'll say i never
i don't trust anybody who turned who
doesn't eat meat and turns down a blow
job
like he'll just say [ __ ] that's that's
that's funny
that's funny and true and the thing with
guys like him and jack
shaq was an auxiliary policeman like
yeah
he was in he loves cops his father's in
the military
his biological didn't bother we all know
that uh that's from his song
from philip is my father because
biological didn't bother he was a rapper
in the early 90s
what i happen to be around like that
that's uh i believe a song
is his uh snack he has the snacks um
so uh so i don't i'm not
those guys are not pre they are a little
bit
they're a little bit republican yeah
that's the
funny thing and i get it it's fine every
i think everyone should be able to speak
i mean
i'm not gonna say it sounds like i'm
saying shut up and talk about sports but
no that's fine we can but it i just find
it it's like
back when i used to use facebook there's
one dude in high school
and he his parents were really um
more white right-wing
and i would any time he would never say
anything about anything i ever posted
except when i posted about oscar grant
which was the black kid that got killed
on the bar
um and then it was like
typing away and i just felt like you
only come
and chime in and chirp chirping when
you wanna you wanna be like devil's
advocate in a really controversial way
not like yo let's talk about everything
it's really he only and then when the
cop got
manslaughter or whatever he chimed in
again like all these
he always wanted to show the like right
wing yeah
opinion that's fine but it just feels
weird when on cue you can be like not
saying anything about anything that's
is are you is charles barkley making
statements
i can tell you about what is [ __ ] up
not necessarily these
i think what he was saying was
this isn't as black and white as
everybody makes the team it's not
it's not a it's not a gimme it's not a
slam dunk it's not uh open and shut
casey doesn't that's the funny part
though it
that's what people want they want a mod
arbory uh the most innocent i'm an
innocent black person like
oh my god and then i got shot i don't
like new ones this is
i have this nut written down for for
trump late
later we'll get to it but i don't
yeah people want a [ __ ] they wouldn't
they wanted
[ __ ] perry mason like who done it
and the weapon was on you check your
shoe
what but that's what they want they want
a [ __ ]
uh 40 minute digestible we have to
normal
but we have to normalize the reason why
i don't like is because it's like let's
normalize
like of right i just put out a best of
luck banner if you want to break through
this
okay i'm gonna tell you what we have to
normalize you tell me if it's best of
luck or not we have to normalize
black and brown people maybe not being
the most
innocent but still not deserving to be
killed and not comparing them
to our you know our one wikipedia
example of like
he did not he was gentle he was going on
a run he was
attractive it's like no not everybody's
like that people some people are
[ __ ] and they still don't deserve
to die
because they're black absolutely but as
i should like
believe i said on the on this
award-winning podcast
it's very vodkas white people consider
black people everything blind people do
is
at a minimum is trespassing
minimum no matter what by being
sentient you're trespassing
on white existence so
well i shot yes because
uh she was in kentucky
it's true do you understand that
literally how upsetting
a non-white person to be in kentucky
it's [ __ ]
terrifying for so even though she's
asleep
at home it's all trespassing so
the the fact that she dated a drug
dealer is just corroborating evidence
and we've all dated a drug dealer speak
for yourself
i have used to pay for burritos with
chicks and
i loved him i mean people would say that
i wrote a movie about drugs and i'd say
you shut your mouth
it was so good someone would say that i
i've encouraged drug use
i actually had a thought the other day
about that
my dad used to not let us watch miami
vice
because he said it glamorized drug use i
think he just read a newsweek article
about it
did it weren't they fighting it he
here's a as a kid i didn't i was you
know 10 or whatever and i was like oh
i'm [ __ ] gonna watch it but
um i should have talked about it during
the rules uh
but the rules he's right
tv glamorizes everything it it
everything's being glamorized
everything it turns its gaze upon is
glamorous
other than uh
like perp walks and [ __ ] like that there
that which is just
just looks gross because it's all
concrete the shot is gross
it's like bard open the door here comes
a perp
and he's got his hands behind his but
even then sometimes purplebox you they
they make
the the actor look kind of badass no no
i'm not talking about the actor i'm
talking about
everything i'm talking about the news at
this point oh the news at perp walks
tupac had some of the greatest purple
blogs of all time you can be done
when tupac did the george jefferson yeah
coming out like that's a [ __ ]
that's one of the great i mean that's on
my top top
you got to start walking like up to the
stage
uh i walk like john gotti where i come
out
where you you put your hands out like
this and you act like you got a big gut
uh but no the two box perplex fantastic
uh so shout out to my dad and r.i.p and
sorry about three months um
um should i leave no no you know what i
was gonna also say is
why what happens to someone like me and
it happens to you too
when you play devil why a person plays
devil's advocate
is because you resent
group think and you resent the fact that
no one will say no one mentions
in certain when they have the brianna
taylor conversation
no one mentions that her boyfriend did
fire his gun
so as if you're any if you're charles
barkley that's
he mentioned it yeah as someone who was
like
part of that's part of the thing it's
someone i didn't know it
for instance the problem is that they're
saying
not that the problem is not that he shot
he's they're saying that he shot first
and they responded
of course which is could be false
whatever but if you're charles barkley
any time
the only time i play devil's advocate is
when
not the only time breathing is is is
when i'm awake
um is when there's a
willful ignorance of a certain fact
right that just makes me [ __ ] go like
what are you thinking
are we watching the same yeah it just
makes it right and like everyone's like
yeah and it's right and you're like what
are you [ __ ] talking about
most of standup is like what right what
are you talking about i
try to pick things that aren't going to
make people hate me
but it's mostly like nature's healing
no it's not nature's naughty like to do
a joke about nature
because it's like shut the [ __ ] it's
you're lying
to fit this narrative that is
demonstrably [ __ ] but the problem is
that your
devil's advocate you guys are similar in
that you do
kind of you have the same outlook on
telling your opinion
yeah but i feel like this kind of
opinion rhetoric or whatever it does
take away from the fact that
it's completely unjust and you're just
really slicing
well we shouldn't uh you know compare
things
so i feel like you do take up for him
because it's like look i get him in a
lot of ways
because you guys are similar but yeah
this hill is like
it's problematic because we want
ahmad like the white world wants a mod
arbory today
that's what we want we want it to be we
don't want them to die
we want them to be that clear so evil
look at those evil whites
those are yeah those are no but no white
people are like that they had guns
vigilantes he was so gentle like that
everybody falls on the same side
it's a civil rights movie a mont arbory
is a is a scene it's a poorly shot
foreign yeah like what is it time to
kill
yeah any one of those movies or yeah or
or
i mean it's forest gump basically yeah
um so
including a truck running yes
um so
yeah so i'm with you i mean the
silent exec producer chris rock says
he's the silent show oh yeah yeah
um is uh that
republicans lie and democrats just omit
facts which is like that's so barkley
sees that
and he's like wait a minute yeah first
of all
see what a good impression people think
that might be one of will's drops
first of all um
and the yeah i guess they
12 million dollars i don't i it's it's
like not like
oh you know what you know i thought i
had which is
in terms of protests there we go
i thought of an idea for that blind
people could use it's not it's
it's not going to work because you're up
against white people and they're
there yeah um but if if instead of
saying we're marching for brianna taylor
it is that uh we're marching for our
freedoms
freedoms white people multiple
is that's the white bat signal is
freedoms
because it doesn't it's vague and
guns and well freedoms
they almost if black people said no
we're trying to get freedoms
i think even the most racist white
people would be like freedoms
they always pluralize it freedom our
freedoms
no they always pluralize freedom it's
like a [ __ ] a white march
we're here for freedom freedoms they're
not freedom it freedom is not
freedoms is like guns no mass there's a
litany of freedoms
and um
ranch freedoms is what white people are
really about
i love doritos i haven't had a dorito
i've had a dorito i literally haven't
had a dorito
probably since the early 90s a cool
ranch just reminds me of being high in
high school
yeah me too uh me and me too and also
the entire earth
um the so
try substituting we're marking you guys
get that
and just say until the wednesday march
yeah uh please
um we'll put in one of those hot
drops grace
trump's taxes dude that was last
that dropped like last yesterday evening
yes like a hot mixtape um
i didn't know what it i just saw it
i s like earthquake or somebody posted
about i was like you got it from
earthquake
i get a surprise probably 20
of my information is from earthquakes
instagram
um that's so weird well
um one time he well he's great
he uh when i worked at the
comedy union yeah um he
like he uh he not he professored me
you know when dave's on stage and like
makes fun of the nutty professor
everyone's laughing he did that to me
like because me and him were really cool
yeah yeah and like talk [ __ ] sometimes
he asked me for water and i was like
like jokingly right
and he was like you got an attitude on
stage
yeah well he was on stage and i kind of
like laughed it off and then he
proceeded to
just rip me
for i it felt like what felt like
forever yeah
and i didn't understand i mean it was
off i was traumatized
i was like what the [ __ ] was that and
then was it
like personal no or was it like
this [ __ ] no no it wasn't personal to
me it was like this [ __ ] thinks
she works but like just the dynamic
but it was the way i treat you off off
mike yeah the way you treat
will on my face okay um so i it was so
awful and that was like my
and i had to keep serving and then
people wrote like and
when he got off he was like ah you know
yeah and i was like
[ __ ] you dude like that was so
embarrassing and awful
people wrote on the receipts you did
have an attitude
like zero tim like oh this is that from
then on
i was like never ever ever
i never i will never play first with
someone with a microphone
yeah that's smart no remind yourself of
that when we start
when we when we record i do technically
have a microphone
you do too but i do do okay sorry go
ahead
is your cnn yes and and i'm will's or
will's white earthquake um
uh so so did you
how much so i i read the new york times
article yeah
it was [ __ ] long to the point what
somebody had done
uh another writer had done like 19
takeaways so i just went to that after
probably reading for 20 minutes
back i i read it i read it for a while
and i skipped and then i was like [ __ ]
i skipped something important
so then you turned on tv but the problem
and this speaks to what i was saying
about the amount aubry thing is
trump's scandals are
one step too complicated
to follow clearly and what he can say
is this is just corporate taxes
what he can trick poor people into
thinking that's how rich people do their
taxes
and he can so that and so he can trick
poor people
and he can also go why it's smart
which is what he's done in the past i'm
a smart businessman okay
so i definitely agree with you but this
one the good thing is most people are
not like me and you and they're not
reading
that and they're not even they're not
even subscribed to
new york times so what
the smart thing is what you know
political media does is they just said
he paid 750 bucks in taxes and that's
easy
now the problem with that he's it's like
either no taxes and then 750 so that
is a grabable line people like i'm a
nurse and i pay this
it's just not even it doesn't have to be
the reality
i actually all right you ever look on
instagram
yes at some you've been on instagram
okay if you
if you look at you ever look at
someone's followers
and it's like 670 and you're like
how does earthquake only have 670
followers
and then then you see the k
and you're like oh 670 000 followers
with trump with that headline i wish
he'd paid
like 1300 750
in my mind somehow my mind
kept making it 750 000 like just
something about the
i wish it had been a different number
for
i don't know i think that's a stretch
yeah maybe i don't know that's just what
my brain did to it
and my award-winning brain
i hope people are smart enough to know
750 is 750
yes but i hope they do i hope they do
let's assume they do
yeah okay let's because that's just like
because
you've seen it everywhere it's even not
not as many people are talking about the
fact that you paid zero
yes 750 is the most
well he's not a cheapskate he's gonna
kick in a little something
the problem is it looks so out of touch
to everyone it's not he's not out of
touch
he's one of the worst
human beings that's ever lived i i'm i
just i'm just there now yeah i'm like
oh you're a [ __ ] horrible like a
horrible person worse than you can even
it all
everything is worse than you thought it
could be yeah were you like ah you
probably paid like a million whatever
right
right off the bat like to put this in
perspective
when the bailout happened during this
cove the covet the twelve hundred
dollars
for whatever my accountant
emailed me it was like hey because
you're incorporated
you you're in you can get 1500 whatever
i could get
um and then about an hour later
he was like you know what don't because
if if people heard it would be bad pr
now he represents me and a bunch of
other comedians
uh showbiz people likes people with real
money like eddie murphy
and chris and [ __ ] wanda [ __ ] like
that but name them all mention it all
uh tracy morgan of course who can forget
tina fey but so it's one not more for
it's more for them than me
but it's more like he was like
it would look bad if eddie murphy got a
twelve hundred dollar bailout so just
don't take it
you don't need the money yeah exactly
whereas trump's the kind of guy
who goes am i getting uh
the you know his lawyers and and
financer
financial guys look for [ __ ] like that
to take advantage he'll say it's smart
and
i would say it's
so [ __ ] cr it's so beyond corrupt
so gluttonous like because we've all
done a scam or two come on now
yeah yeah you do it in moderation and
when you're 20.
yeah i mean when you're younger when
you're [ __ ] broke you do a scam when
you're rich you don't you just there's
kind of like ah it's not worth the
trouble one time i was or when you're an
adult well i was in an arcade
and the machine broke and it gave me so
you might not want to talk about this in
the podcast tilt in san jose
uh uh they gave me they're very
litigious i know tilt
i work with tilt all the time um so and
it was hard to get tickets there and i
it gave me hundreds
100 like i maybe 500 tickets and you
would not have gotten that and they
you could tell i didn't get that much
for the amount of time i'd been there
so plus everybody knows you're not that
good you're not going to know i was
trying to get a tekken i was not that
good
so i me and my brother made a plan we're
like all right we're going to hide these
in the
arcade so we hid them behind a like a
whatever
an arcade game and we're just going to
take a little bit every time so it
doesn't look completely obvious that
this machine is broken gave us way too
many tickets and it was fine
but in my head i'm like if that was
trump he would be like
yes this is all i'm a winner i
won look and then he would double down
look how good i am i won
so many tickets yeah like he doesn't
think like i'm getting away with a lot
did i say on here that the founding
fathers
wouldn't have been able the same way
they couldn't fathom it's like
you [ __ ] are
you want you're so you're [ __ ] you
have
no more like no more they're they
and they see it as a feature they not a
bug like they
they're proud of that who's that trump
um
uh [ __ ] mitch mcconnell people like
lindsey graham
i think that they
because the thing is a lot of those
republicans like lindsey graham and
whatever
they were elected you know before trump
was even a thing
so they're really doing everything
they're just betting on horses like
what's going to get me reelected
they're all up for real i don't i mean i
gave
dude well yes scary yes well
um good even better oh it's funnier just
get scared
my dog walker may come and scare the
[ __ ] out of you
i mean we'll cut it out but it was
pretty good
nobody knows he's worried about audio um
his allegiance is to audio and audio
suck only dick and choke on it
so yeah they're so
they i donated to lindsey graham's
opponent last night oh god i was like
um no like black dude yeah who's like a
goofball
probably not gonna win but i'm like ah
anything
except for lady g yes just a [ __ ] p
that guy's a piece of [ __ ] and you want
they're unamerican
i don't care that much about america as
like a
[ __ ] i don't think it's the greatest
kind it's like what are the stats
right that's the greatest country
whatever the whatever the stats are
whatever's number one in each category
is the greatest country in that category
um but these mother that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
wrong like dude you're that's wrong
well liberals are just no they're not
they're not just as bad
like like gorsuch was
kind of centrist yeah and obama was
putting him up like hey there's a guy
he's not like a bleeding heart super
lefty he's kind of centrist like
gorsuch had gotten endorsements from
bush
right and like that era so he wasn't
trying to he wasn't flame throwing
um yeah these are two different people
like they're
so immoral
and the people that like him
are it's starting to be a little bit
like
nazi territory to me where you're like
what are you what the [ __ ] are you doing
what are you like what are you doing
what's your idea what is your ideal what
is your ideal what are we doing here
because
the fact that the they just
say anything yes they just say anything
and the problem is that i mean
politicians aren't known
for being you know of high moral
with having high moral business yes yeah
so it's like okay what are we talking
about but i personally think that
if biden i i do think that
left leaning people and liberals would
not support a candidate that
doesn't fall in line like if biden
started doing
weird [ __ ] i don't think people would be
making excuses yeah i think it would be
i mean i can't think of an example
uh republicans would say mo anything
that they do like
anything that liberals support is is so
far
like but no but you know what support uh
defund the police
joe biden was like yes it's an extreme
left position
and he's not like yes i'm going to sign
an executive order defining the police
he's like no
yeah that's a standard thing that we
have in this country
and all over the world that's valuable
the police
right so i'm not just gonna finagle a
way to figure out
pull funding from this to give and
and most liberals are like no we're not
like
we need police i'm trying to think of
times where liberals are really
major hypocrites okay when obama was
deporting a lot of people
mm-hmm it didn't make news like
yeah but it was still but but there are
there's plenty of
liberals that will bring up drone
strikes as like that guy's
he was not yeah you know and i'm a
liberal and i'm like obama was okay
right it's all right um like he's
not i like that he's black he i like him
personally
right but his po he's too he's a little
mild for me personally
right um or
and then yeah so i that it's not exactly
a one-to-one
yeah no i'm just trying not to
yeah but but supporting that guy is it's
they i almost wanted to do a uh uh
daily show piece about this which is
saying a republican's like
hey man we're roommates
like you gotta you can't make the
apartment
we have to live together right and they
don't understand like
so we'll do this and then you'll leave
no it's a [ __ ]
this lease we're locked into this lease
right no one's going anywhere so you
need to make this
a little more livable because this
shit's [ __ ] nuts like you can't
it can't be lights out at 8 30 every
night and you can't start banging a drum
at [ __ ] at six because you you can't
play rivoli because
because you because that's what you want
right you're we're [ __ ] room
we have to agree to some of this [ __ ]
and there's got to be uh
parameters of of what's realistic and
what's acceptable but they've so far
it's a it's a real it's
it's a bummer and it's painful
well you know there is this theory that
so if you to get any national security
clearance you have to they look at how
much debt you have and they were saying
that
that's i guess why jared kushner
originally couldn't get cleared because
he had so much debt
yeah then that debt got paid by deutsche
bank
deutsche bank yeah um but they were
saying that it the reason why they do
that is because it leaves you too
um vulnerable to blackmail and stuff and
he has like 450 million dollars
yes he has 450 million dollars in debt
like coming up in the next few years
trump's going to owe the government a
hundred million dollars potentially like
he can't
dude to the u.s government yeah yeah
well because
how hard do you think they're gonna push
for it the thing is if he gets reelected
the thing is they're going to put a lien
on the white house
they're going to they're going to have
to go to jail [ __ ]
boot on air force one guys
this month you are you if we elect this
guy
there's going to be a big he that's
going to you know how
then i do a black bed about you know
brother with the air force one of the
boot we try to take off without it
go on that was my charles but first of
all you're being a real charles
barkley right now yeah uh oh
no i just is a wigger
black man here
so funny um no there's just something so
when you zoom out obviously all this is
[ __ ] up but when you zoom out we look
incredibly weak weaker than i thought we
were as a country
we're so easily i had a tweet this week
that i i said we're a first world
country that identifies the third world
country
it i could have written yeah but i
really wrote i like the revival i
rewrote it too
we're a third world country that that
identifies the first world country
by the way whenever you go to another
country
and they don't have good infrastructure
it's because they didn't take on all the
debt in the world
which we do we cannot afford
this way of life especially when pieces
of [ __ ] like trump
and most corporations don't pay taxes
that's the funny thing it's like we we
really concentrate on all of us
non-billionaires paying our taxes but
the weird thing is that a lot of trump
supporters and right-leaning people
i mean it's not that hard of a concept
to understand that if you paid
the appropriate amount of taxes you'd
still have so much money left over
and it would help alleviate some of our
national debt but
when you talk about it but you're like a
crazy bernie sanders person yeah who
they think it's going to go to
trespassers
they think the money's going to be no
the black people
oh trespass they think that i call them
trespassers
i was like uh
yeah they think it's gonna go to welfare
queens that's
the [ __ ] welfare like well i don't
but my money i don't want
you're taking my i've never i had this
discussion the other night
i've never
even when i didn't make a lot of money i
never
thought my taxes were too high i just
like yeah it's the cost of admission i
don't know what
like we it's an infrastructure that
needs upkeep and
you pay for [ __ ] i never thought like
the blacks are getting there
are you gonna use verona to buy
timberlands
i never i never assumed the worst about
where my taxes were going
is it way too much military absolutely
but until we until we
start making cuts to places where we
need cuts
it's just funny how we have a theme of
you know republican governments
they're not good with economics they're
worse with economics
trickle down they're significantly worse
with economics because they
they're they're there to prove that
government doesn't work
yeah and they run on government doesn't
work it's corrupt
and if you don't and if you elect us
we'll show you how poorly it works
because we'll make
we'll just rig it yeah they will rig it
so
i don't get how though literally he's he
did away with
um expenditures right like things you
can write off
he did away with him or yeah or he um
he changed the tax to say like hey you
can't write off a bunch of [ __ ] anymore
who did trump did he pass all these
no it's no no he he made it
the tax cut the corporate tax rate went
from like 26 to 21.
like it's no i'm saying for but everyday
people but here's the thing and i say
this
as as a guy who you wouldn't know it my
father was a corporate tax attorney
these [ __ ] they my dad would go
to work every day
to cut the taxes for sarah lee
all these corporations commodore
computers
and try to just there's a department
yeah reading laws and looking for
loopholes
so i've ne i go to h r block
they're not there right they're they're
not lawyers
they're just guys who understand the
data input
basically mine i was a [ __ ] tax
lawyer so these guys
and he's just one of thousands yeah they
have
they have armies of these [ __ ]
and they're all as cold as my father
and that if you take nothing away from
this episode
um so they they're gonna find loopholes
i don't think it's again it's not that
what trump did may not have even been
illegal the the
laws are so [ __ ] warped they think
that it was illegal
that most of it wasn't but it was
it was like a law where like okay if you
have so much loss in your business yeah
and of course
forever and then you fudge the law yeah
the loss
he would overstate losses and understate
profits
that's which that is illegal but
but and how many people doesn't pay
taxes like the amount of people that
don't pay
amazon barely pays taxes if you're a
multicultural a
multi-national corporation you you're
paying [ __ ] [ __ ] meanwhile yeah oh
what i'm
my business is the caymans what are you
talking about yeah i'm just here
visiting
coca-cola no um from america
yeah like they um
uh the uh moving on moving on
great um brad pascale
par scale did you see that video which
one that guy
is this in florida just straight up by
looking at that video yeah it's florida
um too big a house two boards
[Music]
no state taxes because i don't want to
go into these black people
yeah um he
he said he tried to kill himself but
then there was more
reporting today that
he he was drunk threatened his wife with
a gun
called the cops the wife called white
wife went to the neighbors
called the cops and that's that's really
oh yeah that's trump's guy
yeah that that pretend victimizing
people and pretending you're the victim
it's like yeah
you're oh [ __ ] you already work for
trump because i was gonna say
he would love free he would love to hire
you
so brad pascale you're a piece of [ __ ]
speaking of piece of [ __ ] we don't often
uh label women piece of [ __ ] but
amy coney barrett amy why are you such a
weirdo
it's not a weirdo it's just oh you
didn't grow up with catholics
no she's part of the cult the
charismatic christians
no she's part of that cult they're
called the
family of something or the they're a
charismatic christian organization
oh i don't [ __ ] know um i do which is
why i said
good feeling um and it says yeah but
you're snapping at me
about like [ __ ] [ __ ] you're good no
that's the corporation no one's snapping
um uh yes
[ __ ] christians are very weird and
there are many sects
uh going back i mean the
newer one again any new religion is
crazy uh
but she's very christian and she's
going to be a supreme court justice for
40 years
because she's 80 she's 43
or something and she's we're going to be
hearing about this nightmare
for uh
the rest of our lives potentially i mean
i just don't get how lady g could go
against
her word uh well there's also the
the i mean the the again they're they're
like hold me to my of course but he
doesn't care and then he goes you would
do the same thing and all this stuff
that's why i it just reminded me to give
money to the
other guy because i can't because
that's one of the only uh not the only
nice things
about having money is you just be like
oh [ __ ] you
right okay i'm giving money to your
opponent it's like the it's
it's politics are so backward
dead in america it's not enough that you
vote for the guy
you have to pay for him to run
and then once he gets in you gotta give
him more money
to lobby for [ __ ] so it's like
you it's like girl scout cookies
girl scout comes to you and goes hey you
want some girl scout cookies you go yeah
let me get 100
worth of thin mints and then six months
later you're like hey where are my
things they're like
you know what that was just to get me to
the factory
i need i'm gonna need another right now
i'm actually gonna need 400
because just to turn the cookie machine
on i know i donated
during the primaries i was like stop
hitting me up
oh they don't stop hitting they need
you bianca they're like do you want to
do a monthly
like if you get i don't know what what
what do you want how much money do you
want to never talk to me again
and just try to win don't talk to me i
don't want to talk
you don't got that kind of money there
is no price that's
did i ever tell you that punished also
when you donate
more significant amounts they'll call
you
oh man directly and say do you want to
have lunch
ooh why would lunch i don't want i don't
want to eat with a stranger and hear
about their charity
who's paying for dutch
i am eventually you know what i mean
like
ultimately i'm paying for the lunch it's
like hey you want to go out to lunch for
that you're gonna pay event it's like
[ __ ]
yeah i'm paying for the lunch eventually
but i don't even when i give to colin
kaepernick's
thing they go colin wants to talk to you
i was like i don't want to talk to him
just take the money for the thing it's
for but they're trying to butter you up
for more money in the future
which i also get but i don't
um i'll let you know yeah i'll let you
know but they don't want it
yeah they don't want to make it like hey
what happened to that guy
right they kind of wanna and then i was
talking to somebody who works at a
corporation that they they audit not
profits
and they said the biggest
one of the biggest issues is is donor
relations that
like they let them go by the wayside and
but as
and she's like you're rare you don't
want
to you don't want your name on anything
you don't want
yeah i don't just do the thing you said
you do i don't want a
guy i don't know don't call me i think
mark kelly the guy who's running for
arizona called me
because that's a new thing yeah well no
there was a message but it sounded like
him like that's another thing they do
where they'll call their donors
individual they'll call like
ford like a radio contest they'll call
the donors directly oh that's nice
it's nice but again just click do you
want to be contacted
that is nice uh i know they don't they
don't have that
they don't give you the option be
contacted you want to you want to take
this to the next level
you want to you want us to pay call you
and then charge you for how much it
costs
um the you know why the
democrats are taking as long as they can
in with the amy coney barrett thing
they're just hoping that a republican or
two will die
that's literally the only thing that
democrats have to not confirm amy coney
barrett
republicans have a majority so now the
only
thing democrats can do is just wait and
hope somebody dies
that's the only thing they have left
it's just like let's just
wait as long as we can and hope that
that seat doesn't that they die and we
can't fill it
and sun is so goddamn important it's so
but it's also so old it's so stupid that
you have to even that you have to be
there to vote
also all these people are old enough to
maybe they'll die
and they're deciding our country's yes
how we're living now
based on after they've already lived
based on like what said
i have to live my values um
what if we put like a age limit on
congress like once you turn 55
like you're out so you really only have
till
yeah i mean i i'm sure that they'll find
a way
to finagle it and actually i
left and i left my coat here and then i
yeah they'll figure out a [ __ ]
thing um did you see the
ilhan omar there so there was a yeah
this guy james o'keefe from project
veritas who makes fake
sting videos for republicans to get
liberals and they are all debunked
eventually uh he was the acorn guy for
obama he was the big acorn guy
um so there's a
a uh ballot harvesting thing
and in minnesota and it's just like it's
if this guy isn't lying the guy in the
video it's
basically a i think muslim
uber driver looking [ __ ] who's
um yeah there it's like you can see my
car is full
i'm harvesting these abs and he's
literally like just giving
dialogue about what he's doing my car is
full
who's doing that uh this muslim dude
again i
i'm saying he's muslim um yeah he gets
bags of money that look like this guy
just makes fake but if this isn't fake
i'll donate to project veritas and
hopefully they'll take me out to lunch
um so that's [ __ ]
um the debates are coming i'm
really excited are you excited
um i do think that this
if biden is preparing well
i think there's so much coming out
the problem is
if they prepare well enough i think they
can just throw him off like i think you
can throw
off trump easily because he's not good
in a debate setting he's not good when
he can't control
i don't think he's i think he's pretty
good in debate settings
did he wasn't good with clinton he
talked over her
no meaning no but she was a good
person for him because she was like must
remain presidential the whole time
and he [ __ ] he's like cakewalk
whereas biden i think they're
but what's the difference i don't think
biden is i think he's
he's he enjoys the he he believes in
decorum
but i he's more he i think he could talk
a little more [ __ ] than
hillary's not like just don't think she
was ever cool
i don't i think it's a tie for second
yeah
between those two and targeting talking
[ __ ] cause i i can't think of
any time blindness zingers i'm just
saying i can
i don't think biden's gonna like just
the whole like
yo you know i'm i'll i'll debate you in
words
you could have urine it's hilarious if
biden wrote that
i'll donate to project veritas another
donation
to project veritas um uh no i just think
that they're
more even match i think they will they
will uh
i think they're just cut from similar
cloths
i think you're underestimating djt
and i remember the last round
with clinton i've already i'm already
betting that
that he's gonna donald that he's gonna
win the election
no no i'm talking about the debate oh
here's the thing all right so
just looks like who's gonna look here's
the and i don't know if i've shared this
on here
probably not
during when he debated hillary yeah i
was watching
one of the i think the second debate the
lurking one the one where
that was yes okay so
when he debated hillary i we watched it
at the daily show
i was working at the daily show and and
uh debate ends and me and trevor look at
each other and go
she didn't she lost yeah
everyone disagreed with us no we didn't
no no and we were like okay
but we know the thing about stand-up is
it doesn't matter the audience doesn't
care about
facts they don't care about they care
about [ __ ] killing
the battleground states minneapolis i'm
sorry
uh minnesota especially just the midwest
ohio indiana michigan illinois wisconsin
and western pennsylvania
who would you have a harder who would i
have a harder time following
at the pittsburgh improv
donald trump or joe biden
maybe trump i have a
absolutely harder time in 2016
and now following trump yeah because
it's a [ __ ] show he's more
charismatic than
than biden and the other thing is
he doesn't he nothing no none of the
rules apply
so you've got in some ways it's like
when i'm on stage with chappelle
and he'll i always say when i heard one
more on stage
i had my jokes have to be [ __ ]
perfect
to get half of the laugh he gets
from sipping his water right smoking a
cigarette yes so
because he's more charismatic he's got
for the litany of reasons why
every now to the layperson you go well
he's funnier than you
yes but he's not that much funnier than
me
it's all the it's all the intangibles of
charisma they they like him more they
want him to win they so so trump has all
these things going for him
that biden kinda can't fight
the minute you start saying like he
he there's not a thing biden can say
that trump can't just like ignore i
think that
strategy worked better in 2016 because
which one uh just really ignoring
points that hillary made like she made a
lot of good points it didn't really
matter
it was her delivery but and that's the
the way
trump in some ways his his debating
tactics are the opposite
of his scandals which is
they're so simple and they make no sense
but they're incredibly simple they are
but this is where you leave yourself
vulnerable the problem is
back in 2016 and there wasn't
that much there was not there was no
history to draw right
so because there's so much to take from
and there's so many
bad moves based on him
that sort of that sort of fighting style
works
at that time period but i think now not
done
no no i know now i think the problem
with that super super simple way of
doing it
like it's so simple it's like genius
that it worked
i think now he you can get um you can
get a zinger on him and if he doesn't
snap quickly or it's not funny like you
can out
simple him give me an example no no
no in so no one in the press has been
able to do it
no one else aren't sparring with him he
can leave he can leave a
he can leave a even interviewers chris
wallace it's the he just
all he does is we're gonna look it up
and then you're done
but again all of these they're playing
even when they're playing hardball with
him they are playing softball with him
because he's
you know he's a hair trigger when he
gets sensitive and he can leave it
any of you can shut it down or whatever
and they have to still kind of respect
the fact that he's the president
but like in when he did that town hall
with chris walls and that black lady was
like
don't interrupt let like if you out
do him at his thing i don't think he has
good
hillary was so different than him that
he could just play the like
even when he agreed with her he
interrupted her and he was like true
you know he just kept doing his thing
but
um it's almost like i remember when i
watched the the
def jam the new version that came out
the anniversary or the anniversary
that came out and dl was on with dave
and it was like
dude like you just let that i would
that's actually a bad example of
what i was saying because chappelle was
so [ __ ]
it was like the funniest thing i've ever
seen him do
and i've seen him do everything he's
ever it was like [ __ ]
it was amazing but just for the
argument's sake
if you put omar apps there at least
they're like
silly enough like to in the symbol and
omar absolutely no
omar epps and dave i'm not saying why
omar
mike gibbs mike absolutely yeah yeah
omar epps from juice
you're like my him
i'm sorry mike they both are
this kind of can pull from the air and
make something funny i feel like that
could have even gelled i'm not saying
it would have he's the same we're
comparing them on the same funny level
but they both do their own
thing in a similar way that i feel like
that could have worked that our deal was
set up
for failure
there was no way dave was so
non-linear in that let's just take that
for specific right but i would say you
yes but i don't think that
biden is to
trump as my guest mike says to dave
i think he's i don't know maybe i'mma i
just you can't
literally you can't get trump in a
[ __ ] you literally
can't hold him cause he doesn't he
doesn't have bones
right he doesn't have ligaments people
like that because it's so simple
what you have to do is you just have to
out zinger him because his zingers
aren't that's why
but no but here's the problem he's
killing it
you're wrong will look it up and then
what he's
he's been promising healthcare every two
weeks
for four years i just think and doesn't
care
that's the thing is there is he doesn't
live in reality
so you can bring you're bringing reality
to a sci-fi fight
basically but you can just sit there and
instead of
fighting him on his level you can just
be like got a lot of this guy you know
if you do it right
you can do it i mean these dum dums
outer space i'm saying like as as long
as you can just take
the put him in context
i he'll just lie i don't know that's
like who knows that's just me
right but he'll my but what i'm saying
is the black lady who was like don't
interrupt
[ __ ] didn't make it didn't make him
didn't leave a mark
on him well the point was not to leave a
mark so you know i'm just saying that
but it didn't leave a mark on trump
right that wasn't the takeaway
that wasn't the takeaway wasn't did you
see that lady
get him on his heels a lot i saw it a
lot like in my feed that was
right i don't know that this this speaks
to the feed thing which is
didn't make a difference to [ __ ]
western pennsylvania
that's not what i'm saying i'm just
saying that like
if you can come at him with like out
energy him you know he stopped he didn't
argue with her he was just like he
stopped
talking about i think he knew it was bad
luck well of course he knew he was about
that you know but
even he thought no was a bad luck um he
would have if she was a reporter he
would have called her
uh disgusting yeah filthy um
you trespasser um
this is not uh news we are moving on
moving on
you know what else is moving on tomorrow
a little
piece of the inside of my nose you're
going to do anything with this
no you're not going to do anything it's
a good point i can't
i'm joking no i know but did i tell you
about the cat scan
yeah i got a cat scan did i talk about
it on here yes
just do a recap maybe someone didn't
hear less i got a i mean
you want to look at a bur you want like
if you saw
my profile you go oh it's a bird and
but i can't it's too late this is
actually why glasses work on me because
it covers the bump
um because before it was like are you
gonna do anything with that bump like
are you guys gonna have weird noses of
course
um i like like for instance brad pitt
i like guys with big noses uh no i know
you i was gonna say you do
yeah but i think generally women just
want you to look like a nun
um if given their brothers just look
like if you can look like brad pitt
what's the date of nine um
uh it's a lesbian earlier now uh
so i'm going in so pray for me are you
going under
no i'm just [ __ ] around i'm sorry
what you're getting no it's out there
yes it's that's the new thing so it's
pretty awesome
i don't i can't remember which one
they're doing there's a radio frequency
thing that they can stick into your
cartilage
and kind of cauterize it yeah it
makes it like that and it it it
uh reduces it like the the the the
cartilage goes like
for it's gonna be so vibrating on your
nose
i can't wait uncomfortable i love it
what if you sneeze during it
like don't sneeze we're in a lot of
trouble no i think they anesthetize it
but it's not
you need someone to pick you up is that
why you're ringing no i will drive your
tesla
um no i don't actually and the last time
i got
real surgery that i needed to go under
for i faked him out
which is uh i got no i had somebody come
and pick me up
and then they dropped me off a block
from the
hospital where i'd left my car because
neil brennan
neil neil brennan that's don't play by
the rules that person already made that
i didn't you know what's
would have been worse is having to be in
the back of a smelly uber i like to
i just like driving myself if i can why
don't you get a friend
too much trouble all right friendship
have you had a friend
they're not great
uh i apple tv i got a one week
membership
when i tell you that there are eight
original things on apple tv i [ __ ] am
not kidding
there might be none that's sad like
don't launch the tv like just give it a
second guys
right just wait until you have i don't
know 20 things
right they don't it's all they have
their nine things and then they just
have like watch the comey rules like
that's show time
yeah i'm going to go to you for stopping
after the
so i watched boys state which people
kept telling me to watch
good no
scripted reality documentary documentary
about basically like a student
government thing
like a high-end student government thing
in texas
student government what like the like
model u.n
but by the way it was all they separated
them boys and girls
and the boys so it's boys
and i just it was not the i don't like
teenage boys
they are gross so what were they doing
that's they were like doing a government
like
they're running for office for this fake
thing
uh but all it just looked it just
smelled like farts to me even though it
didn't
it's not like b.o farts and like jerk
off
just too much just like just all 16 17
year old guys
and is it interesting
not to me but they were just running for
an office did you
do something corrupt they would kind of
fudge and they would like move positions
and they made like
videos they made like memes about the
other side
and interesting and that was the whole
documentary yeah man
just about them running for 49 hour 49
wow not easy and then
the uh then the there's a beastie boys
movie one's indian are they both indian
uh
no but one kid i like the indian kid it
was good
um also i think he was latino
lettings the tanks um yes
uh so whatever and then there's bcboyz
movie or documentary the beastie boys
story based on their book
and i gotta say
huh it pains me to say this
but i didn't and spike jones directed it
and i wasn't a fan so these are dock
watches
that you didn't like yeah you're good
for the goose good for the gander
there's by the way there's a front line
the choice about buying and trump that i
didn't watch so that i could watch these
because my membership was ending
and i i never again are you going to
renew never again
no there's not what i'll give it another
five years when their next nine things
are ready
they're gonna take forever these people
here's my issue with the bc boys it was
basically a live
like a one-man show with mike and adam
right
um and uh
a new concert no music they didn't sing
or they didn't rap they didn't do any of
their music
they just talked about their
story which fine they didn't memorize
their lines
so there's a teleprompter and and what
the other word
i know and it's like fellas so are they
just like
it's like an snl it was worse
no it was worse than that because
they're both
very charismatic good funny
interesting guys and but
their their writing was like little did
we know
that everything was about to change i
mean that was actually like a
bit like the song that changed
everything they just repeated it like
five times then
it but they would go like our friend
adam
was an enigma wrapped up in a riddle
and it like their performances were so
weird like fellas a
memorize the [ __ ] because you're doing a
theater and then you're going to
broadcast it
and like the early mixtapes if they just
said them
it was like the it was like uh after
school special version
of like and then rick came in
and we were like what and he was like
you guys got to hear this
it was [ __ ] bizarre like why are you
doing this like horvitz is a
great [ __ ] performer yeah like a gr
like
in terms of acting and like as a guy and
mike
could have there was a way for mike to
do it
that he could have been it was [ __ ]
like why are you doing this
i don't know to sit through that and
like you want to talk about like a
band that had a huge
like i knew them yeah i loved their
music
yeah they're white rappers who were
actually
good right and weren't eminem you know
what i mean like that weren't
that they weren't they weren't like it
was fun was it
like a bio biopic sort of story of their
life
or was it it was a story of the band but
yeah that's what i mean
of them the beastie boards yes it was
the story of the band like
i was 13 and i went downtown to cbgb
yeah they had a video behind them uh
they had like mostly
photos and [ __ ] behind them oh no but i
it was one of these things like this is
so easy to correct but
here's the bad news it's gonna take you
five hours to memorize it
how long is the show two hours
oh my god live it was three which is
like woo
please um no i mean
dude i've memorized people memorize
memorize it
bullet point actually and if they had
bullet pointed it they would have
it would have been more natural right um
and there was like little sides between
them that were kind of funny but
but it was like ah it was infuriating
because like you know you could do this
well
right it's gonna take like i said
five hours and you are gonna have to try
a little bit i'm sorry
but i'm [ __ ] begging you
to just do just try it just try it just
tell me
tell me the version how would you say
that normally
right you would go like our friend adam
was such a special guy and then
yeah so that was a real bummer um but it
was still like good
but it but it was like slightly like a
missed opportunity
a rough a missed opportunity that they
they
i felt like they hid behind
that that's their intention but it's
like
it sounds like an aperture just go
special it sounds like a book report
like it's [ __ ] bizarre so i saw a
documentary
did you know i love my true crime errol
morris
came out with the i know i didn't watch
that also
wilderness of error yes and it's
[ __ ] great so the first three
episodes are out
yes that's nice and it's about
hulu's got hundreds of things at least
ten
yes um it's almost like an old school
version
of uh making a murder
because it talks about a i guess very
famous case from the
mid-60s that happened with the
army medical officer so it's really i
don't even remember what making a
murderer is
making murder of the guy the guy with
the the guy with the
the burn barrel oh great yeah
so it's really cool so they basically i
i'm three episodes and i
don't know i'm like wait did he did he
not
basically guy his family gets murdered
and he gets attacked
and um he said hippies came in and they
a girl in a white hat a negro and two
men and they
they wrote pig like imitating the um
the charles manson thing and it sounds
like a lot of the details are really
far-fetched
it's like when i when i read jessie's
smallette yeah it's like
i'm the gay tupac like yeah i don't know
you know
whitney texted me the jesse smollette
thing
the morning it happened and i wrote back
this didn't happen
wow really yes and she was like what i'm
like this didn't happen
and then i'll i said to a hall of fame
comedian
who will go unnamed uh
i smell a rat and he said i just spoke
to rats they said leave us
out that's a really fun yes so the story
is very jessie's mullet
juicy and uh like everybody's killed he
only has a few puncture rooms
everybody in the house has different
blood his blood is conveniently only
over the sink like all this stuff where
it's like no
you think it's a slam dunk like four
hippies whatever
then you start realizing like duh for
hippies
they parked and yeah uh this actually
yeah
there's all this stuff they left out of
the case there's all this
information of people where it's like
did this far-fetched story actually
happen or did this guy
lose his [ __ ] mind and kill his
family and it's so it's really good and
it's the
arrow morris touch of the um he has
those like dramatizations
yeah yeah so the by the way if you if
you haven't do you ever see tabloid
no i think it's on hulu it's an errol
morris movie
it's a secret banger
yeah i saw that his first one titty cut
follies right was that
yeah i was sad yeah um
although i don't did he do that
um it's tabloids like six seven years
ago it's really really good
it's him is it just like a deep down
no it's fine tabloid from 2010.
um is it does it follow a storyline yeah
is it just but the story
the story's [ __ ] really odd
really it's like a woman faking the it's
the it's the
uh a woman
who in 1977 was accused of kidnapping
and raping kirk anderson an american
mormon missionary
oh my god but yeah i was wrong it wasn't
him
um yeah no okay cool so i've seen i've
seen a thin blue line i've seen
another one florida vernon florida
really good yeah yeah and then
i think someone suggested fog of war was
great
um um but i haven't seen tabloid
um yes so let's do some letters
well moving on l s t
n e r
[Music]
[Applause]
that's nice hey what's up everybody my
name is zayn i've been playing video
games pretty much my whole life
you're kidding i've been playing with
the same group of five to six guys
for the past two years on the same game
and
they started picking on me and bullying
me too much so i decided
i'm not going to be friends with them
anymore and i wanted to know
how do you keep the relationships you do
have with your friends
strong and long-lasting thanks again
zane peace out that's so [ __ ] up
that well that's uh that's young
boy's state is him 10 years earlier just
going like yeah i'm [ __ ]
i'm a i'm a see i believe in small
government and he's like oh [ __ ] i gotta
get out of here
um zane zayn
why are they picking on him well did you
see his hair i'm kidding
then i start going like do they say
things like it and then i just have a
litany of things
um do they say things like
this i can't do it um uh
[Music]
friendships saying
friendships are
many splendored no i don't know yeah if
they're mean you just go i'm not gonna
be friends anymore
i've i've done that to people you gotta
cut it out
out you gotta cut uncle joey
uh i caught a i cut a guy out
28 years ago
and i
just said like you're too much of an
[ __ ] 20
i'm not 28 years 21 years ago and i
think
and then that night i i went to a
concert with mike d i think it was a
pavement concert that's how long ago
this was
at irving plaza in new york and me and
mike
were walking up the steps and the guy
that i cut out was walking down the
steps and he pointed me and goes
dick and he goes dick
ass you're a [ __ ] dick
but because i said you're too mean a
person
and then he just you don't have a good
spirit and i don't want to be friends
with anymore and i
just straight up told him and i just
started going to therapy also
and i was like creating boundaries and
he then proved
yeah what was the matter with him so
should zayn
zayn yes he i think he said he broke up
with him no but should he tell him like
you guys are just
too much no because i my my guess
is they don't care
and my other guess is they they think
they
they like a zane they can push around
yeah
and you're not it's very very difficult
to reinvent yourself
outside of a movie montage well i know
someone who's trying to do a podcast
finally one of the guys i know if they
need a producer i'm looking to get rid
of somebody
i am your white i'm your white
earthquake wills white earthquake
um so i need the one guy kept trying to
make him
the the the fall guy the dumb one on the
podcast and the dynamic
kept doing it and they kept talking he
kept saying like yo
i'm not going to be the dumb guy like
stop trying to make me the dumb guy and
they got an argue like a really big
argument and i thought about him like
man there's some people that
are just comfortable with that dynamic
that like i
i gotta say that was the only like i
don't like uh
i don't like when people do that uh
meaning i was like a crutch of
communication
but as a in in personal lives obviously
they're just going to try to pile on
whoever they can pile on but
i never liked some comedians do that
with their like openers or their and
it's like
man i don't like that just [ __ ] on their
open yeah him like this
loser yeah like i don't like delia used
to do it that was the only i would
that i i never said to him i didn't like
that but that was the thing that i
just was like don't [ __ ] on your openers
right like it's
they're you know but you know [ __ ] on
your producers
yeah it's pretty genuine how hard i come
down on the wheel
yeah well well if you need to play a
song
you should have been playing that well
played just that should play under the
entire podcast
um you [ __ ] you piece of garbage i'm
kidding
goodbye you hate me on bianca
that's literally what it says a question
for all relationships but especially the
ones that are state-certified
i'm assuming that's mary a likes to have
sex
more often than b who's it
on to keep up a fair and balanced sex
life
a taking more swings or b
throwing more bones how neal feel
and what banks latinx
you're truly a oh he's a he's a i didn't
think that i
wasn't sure who he was it's gross um
i i was thinking
just about marriage in general and
the you were in of course
okay okay so you know it was me um
it's such an unf it guys just
want sex like when not just want sex
we have to have sex whereas women it's a
nice thing every once in a while
but a lot of marriages especially flip
and a lot of women
end up wanting sex and guys are not
statistically what do you think of that
is
i mean i think afterwards i think women
like saying that
but i but i i would what i would say is
the story of marriage in in my own
friend's experiences
is nothing it's just they you just
after two years after three years it's
[ __ ] over
and then you have a kid and it's [ __ ]
over it's like really over i heard that
at first it's very much what he's saying
and then
it grows 10 years passes the man gets
completely demoralized and then the
woman's like let's have sex and he's
like
where have you been i think it's more so
i mean look if you
if you're breastfeeding and kissing your
kids on the cheeks like do you really
want to
right part of my french in your wife's
mouth and face yes yeah the answer is
yes
um no but i but of course
sex and family are kind of diametrically
opposed to each other
meaning you got you just
you made roommates
so how
sexy do you think it's gonna be they're
roommates who don't
know that don't know what sex is and
would be horrified to know that what it
is and that you and mommy are doing it
so you're you're just making a situation
where yes you're just not gonna
this is not doesn't lend itself it's not
the sexiest environment
and it's not supposed to be but
i don't i think it's
i don't think i don't think i
i'm i'm of course i'm going to say women
i don't think women care
it's like they're i think that once a
man once a bit once kids start showing
up
mothers especially like oh this is the
good [ __ ]
this is actual love i do think it's
funny that
in society we do uh
guys chase women they court women they
go after them the men
go after the women the women lie there
and
wait and that's our dynamic and then as
soon as we're married it's like
well i thought it was just going to
change because we decided
the guy or the girl the guy thinks
somehow the woman's just going to [ __ ]
him all the time it's like
the hope the whole thing in our heads is
that like
a guide has to try and get right you
know what i mean
which is funny that it doesn't yes but
guys assume that
by dedicating my life to you
that's kind of the ultimate peacock well
women
assume that dedicating our lives you
mean you aren't going to [ __ ] anyone
else
and we're not going to well but right
yeah
guys cheat but not if you [ __ ] them
that is not you can't fire an empty gun
you know the old saying you can't fire
an empty
gun ain't no bullets in an empty chamber
how many different ways is you don't
no guys [ __ ] no guy's cheating
because he's getting so much [ __ ] at
home
i'm i'm assigning you 10 cc's of
watching
waiting to exhale come back to me some
[ __ ]
male female propaganda of like you know
what
that movie should be called you know
what goodbye you've got mail
hey neil and bianca lscner i'm a 32 year
old
tanks gonna steal that one by the way
they said
living alone with a puggle oh that
doesn't really
have to do much with my question but i
just think it's funny that people
preface their emails with that
uh pug of the tinx um my dad recently
died and that's been tough
i had a pretty good relationship with
him because he was just a genuinely kind
man but as i get older i was unsure of
how to talk to him
because he was always incredibly
reserved
neil i know you had a tough relationship
with your dad and bianca i'm not sure
what yours was like but my question is
this do you care to dig into the life of
a dead parent and find out
parts of them you didn't know by asking
the other parent
or do you just let them rest in power
and cherish what memories you have with
them it's a good question
um i don't know i did a lot of digging
while he was alive
well he's like he's a middle eastern man
i'm sure there was
it was archaeological folks and we went
to iran
and so indiana banks
binky anna jones you're behind me
bankrupt no binky yeah um
yeah i did and then we went to iran and
that
i feel like if i didn't go to iran with
him that would have
that would be a real blank space there
but when you
go back to where your parents from and
you see all their old friends and old
folks you went with him
yeah we all went him me and my brother
and um
and yeah i was that was the most
like i know my dad i know who he is
before that
i did but that was like full circle so i
was really happy about that but
let's say i didn't have that or i had a
hole i don't know what if you find
something [ __ ] up
yeah i mean i that's why
yes you might find something [ __ ] up
if you start the
if you start the process you got to
prepare to
you got to be prepared to find out that
he has an apartment downtown
you go you go okay you got to ask family
members like hey i want to know more
like
do you think like give me a clue because
everyone knows something you know
yeah like when people start working at
the store
and i have they never let me train them
first they always let me train them last
because i'm not very organized with my
system
i'm just [ __ ] good at handling
volumes of people i don't know how to
teach it
i'm just like i don't know i memorize
things don't write anything down
um but what i teach them is how to
hustle
at that job and when i give them the
most [ __ ] up time like okay her she's
kind of a [ __ ] she's really nice she'll
help you
like i give them like i tell them the
reality
yes i'm like don't talk to him don't i
and some of it's kind of talking [ __ ]
but i'm like no i'm not gonna
do you wanna know i'm gonna tell you and
so everyone knows
something about somebody that's a little
[ __ ] up so
i'm wondering if she could do some
investigative reporting
to the relatives and see like should i
but i also don't
know why would you want to know more
than what somebody told you
meaning i don't i just i always think
about like if
i the old thing in the in the analog
days was if i die
go and get my porn out of my apartment
before my mom goes right you don't want
to see that
so that's not what they want to see
though right
but do you need do you
if they don't have a secret family if
they
if what do you want to know i don't i
think
i think you should just be the the dead
person
should be allowed to obviously rest in
power
and if they're a great justice rest in
prudence
i wasn't scared because he did a thing
yeah he did a little whimper yeah
but i think that you should be able to i
don't know i just think
whatever someone told you is
that's what that's what they wanted you
to know question
your mom was like i found
your father's diary yeah
do you want to see it you would see it
come on
no no cause i think i heard like one of
my
uncles wrote a book on your dad
no not on my dad just about his life and
there was some illusion to maybe my dad
got
molested or something just but it's
vague
and i don't know that's a
that's actually happened but it's also
proverbially
what good does that do me yeah to know
that
i i but what if you read it and
he was really silly and funny in it and
you're like then that would be fake
well i remember like it's just what a
narcissist would do but
i remember the women who worked it
that worked in my dad's department he
would i one of them was saying like your
dad buys us candy and you're like what
the [ __ ]
like candy yeah uh he brings us cannon
was the [ __ ] out he didn't bring us
candy
um so yeah i don't know
uh i don't i think it's leave well
enough alone and
unless it's
it's the uh i think dan soder i or joe
derose's comic
yeah who did a joke about he's he's
adopted and somebody was like do you
don't you want to find your real parents
and he's like
no they were pretty clear that's kind of
how i feel with people
like whatever i want to know
i'll take your word for it if there's a
side scandal
that's then whatever then we can talk
about that later but
goodbye you've got mail big fan of the
show don't use my name
uh okay uh if you use this
just call me a realistic alias
like rudiger or bruce all right
i find your thought that's what they
call a swinging abyss
i find your thoughts on alcoholism
codependency insightful i love my
alcoholic wife earlier this summer no
kids
after years of living with and obsessing
on her disease
um i'm a big free hairy bird now
am in therapy and i've gotten into some
dating apps um
without digressing too far i moved 30
minutes away but i regularly work
at out of the home office at the house
from whence i fled
while she's at work because we have a
dog together i plan to move further away
in the spring and eventually divorce but
one step at a time
i just got to put that dog to sleep i'm
kidding he didn't write that
um i bring that up because i'm wondering
how much all of this
i should divulge to my bumble matches
i'd ideally like to be totally honest
because otherwise it can turn
uh george costanza pretty quickly on the
other hand i don't
know many people in these parts and
legit want to hear with new faces
want to hang with new faces and maybe
obtain sexual release along the way
don't say sexual release
um i fear giving them the long low down
that i'm separated but it was a long
time coming and she has a disease and
i'll never go back
we'll preclude any fruitful progress
what say you beautiful babies divulge or
occlude it's big [ __ ] words this
guy's got
thanks to binky got bands and ghostface
neela
for the hours of hilarious insight
i staying
married or being married
i think you gotta
that feels like a fifth date divulgence
wait i don't know i first of all i would
say
don't go to the house to work there
yeah the work from home thing like why
do i guess to
walk see the dog see him and bounce
because she's gonna come home
and she's gonna have a dude with him
with her and he's gonna have a gun
i'm kidding um i just don't see any good
coming from that
no um now
i don't know i i you don't want it when
you bring it up it's a
hour conversation on the date it's got
to be i'd say just
when you determine you actually really
like this person and you want to keep
hanging out with them
maybe yeah but if she if he says i lived
in omaha
but i don't live there anymore and she
goes why'd you move what does he say
just kind of fudge it
i had a roommate
i don't know i know i don't i think
fifth date it
and preface it
with we can talk as much or as little
about this as you want
right it seems it on paper it's a big
deal
um but it doesn't have to be
yeah and the the thing that's relevant
about it whether you realize it or not
and whether the
woman the new date woman realized or not
is
the uh psychology of a
person who would be with an alcoholic
for a long time
right that's more relevant than
sit the living situations i think yeah
yeah
i do feel like this could go either way
it might
someone might not like this what what
about it
well just the like i don't i'm just
wondering what
is the appropriate time to disclose it
and someone not be a little like
uh you know you said fifth date
yeah why date one
it's it's it it's like
small talkie dick two is what he did
three you [ __ ] uh you get sexual
release
uh yeah i don't know it's one it's i
there's no right answer
now having said all that if the person
doesn't like it
it wasn't meant to be in the first place
so what if it was meant to be in that
this is weird then it wasn't meant to be
like when should i have
if someone can't do the math that we're
doing right now this crippling math
then they are then [ __ ] them yeah
they're a clown
he's free he's not cheating on her i
mean that should be the most important
thing he's not doing anything yeah
dubious yeah like you can you can call
her she's gonna be drunk
but if you like i this woman exists and
goodbye
et cetera et cetera you finally
misspelled even though it's on
the artwork and the name of the podcast
and the email address
uh i have some questions about aging
specifically for neil
in the past misspelled again she spelled
it right then she went back to wrong
spelling
has mentioned the ages of women he's
dated recently from as young as
mid-20s to as old as late 30s
um he's also made derogatory comments
about menopausal women yep doesn't sound
like me
uh only if they're fat my questions for
neil
are would you date a woman your own age
and two assuming the woman is in good
shape healthy and takes care of herself
do you prefer women who age gracefully
or women who typically
uh who do typical la things to keep
themselves looking unnaturally
young botox etc i'm not asking bianca to
weigh in on this
because she's melanated and ageless she
could be 20 or
50. she's 50. i have no idea and i
imagine she will look like that until
she dies congrats bianca thank you
that's nice sincerely a middle-aged
white woman a lot of a lot of lot a lot
here
lots of lots uh of course i would date a
woman my own age
uh assuming that the woman's in good
shape healthy takes care of herself do
you prefer a woman who ages gracefully
or a woman who does l
typical la thinks to keep themselves
unnaturally young here's the thing about
what la does to you um
well there's a couple things here men
are not observant
so if a woman's had botox
i don't [ __ ] know yeah i have no
[ __ ] idea i truly have not like
people go you know you ever
as a girl you probably don't but you
ever watch as a guy
you'll watch tv or look at somebody
online and the girl be like she did this
yeah and she gets like the john madden
to illustrator like no she had this done
and this is a tummy tuck right i know
nothing the only thing
not the only thing i the lip plumpers
gross me out looks a little weird and
they always the the dead giveaway for
lip plumpers
upper lip sweat they're like they get
mustache line sweat
and it's almost across the board and i
told this somebody the other day and
they go
well they should get botox to get around
like okay you know
uh so
now having said that not a fan of gray
hair
don't want just don't i hope the
stragglies are the whole gray
i i don't want
to be reminded of death that goes for me
and because i believe it bianca because
i
really don't just like what reminded of
don't want to be reminded of death
don't want to be reminded of uh time
passing don't want to be reminded of
it's why i love vegas
um guys the biggest casualty of this
whole kobe thing is that i can't go to
vegas and go to places where there's no
windows and
they pump the air in and shania twain's
playing um
uh yeah i don't i yeah i don't if a
woman
uh dyed her hair until the day she died
i would have no problem with that
and got some kind of if she wanted to
get botox
knock yourself out you're not a sagging
skin fan
i don't know how you stop that this is
by the way
i i'm i'm doing okay now but
i you know who [ __ ] knows yeah
who knows she didn't want my input
give it it's not her show um
i don't know i think it would be nice to
see you with an older lady
i'm gonna be honest why i don't know why
women say that like you know would be
nice what's wrong with that
what's wrong i had a joke with uh a
woman
20 years ago who was in comedy
and uh with it with amy poehler so she
would go like why don't you date a girl
in comedy
and i was like i don't want i don't know
i was and then there was
uh there was uh there was a youtube
video of a girl oh a girl beatboxing and
i forwarded to polar and i go why don't
i date a beatboxer
wouldn't that be nice if i dated a
[ __ ] beatbox why
that why women want to see you with
blank
it's all about your belief system i'm
under attack
it's your belief system how about how
can i pick who i pick
you can i wish you know who you
should i'd like you to date a guy who's
into horses first of all
breathe i'm just saying that right you
said i have no problem dating a woman
my own age and i'm like that would be
nice is you you [ __ ]
you were picturing what what do you mean
you were going older you wanted the
[ __ ] you wanted me to say it'd be
nice
you want to see jane goodall again you
are the one you want
to do grey hair one of these ghost hoes
out here
ah yes dear god apparitions
moving on thank you i'm gonna read the
last goodbye
[Music]
hey neil and bianca long time listener
first time a mailer
a couple weeks ago i was trying to
convince my hispanic grandma that trump
does
not care and has no interest in her
well-being
she's a lifelong republican and says
that she would vote for trump
again because of his platform not
because of
who he is as a person there's
a lot more [ __ ] up info about that but
back to my point
i asked her as a woman of color why
would she vote for a man who most likely
wouldn't
care about only who would most likely
only care about white women if he cared
about women at all
to this my mexican latina looking
grandmother
bonded le tinx look and grandmother
responded
i'm a white lady what do you mean oh god
my grandma has a half italian mother
maybe that's why she thinks she's white
she is definitely a brown lady
my questions are do you think hispanics
are white no
let's have a show right there stop do
you think
hispanics are white how do i tell her
that she is not white
and is being a person of color a mindset
thanks
a [ __ ] confused granddaughter
i have a real easy test take her a
mexican restaurant
if the staff speaks her in spanish
there you go mexican yes um
well they're you know the whole i don't
know how much time we have to unpack the
latin communities deep-seated issues
with itself that's why you're here
representing
um yeah i don't i just there's a lot of
issues in the latin community a lot of
people i remember there was a
like a latin cop something happened
anyways the
chips from chips no no what's his name
michael
michael pena is the new one eric estrada
um he uh no anyways in the something
happened he he fudged up somehow this
cop
and someone said a white like a white
passing hispanic cop and
everyone was like what white passing
what does that mean
so i think there are a lot of there are
a lot of latin people who
really do consider themselves not white
i mean i've never heard that but
not brown you know what i mean
yeah i don't this is one of these things
where i not there are very few things
that i feel
unqualified to talk about you know i am
a late arriving instant expert will
will no will will well don't i don't
need you to google now
now i need songs
what is he googling hispanic
[Music]
also hispanic is a made-up word i think
it's just
the world real world
i always hear that i've heard the
stereotype that
that no one's more racist than a
than a immigrant from that country like
shut the borders down
uh so that just seems like from the same
category as as this i don't
if she thinks she's white what do you
you know yeah
what are you gonna do she's there's no
mirrors in her house yeah she's gonna
she'll if she's grandma age so she's
over
well she's latino so their grandma's
yeah i was gonna say 41.
um that's funny uh she's the tank so
she's 41 year old grandma
um and she's gonna
if she hasn't figured it out by now
she's either delusional
or people treat her like a white person
should we just do let's just come up
with experiments like okay if you're
white then
yeah go to the go to the [ __ ] go to
go to a mexican restaurant and not like
el pollo yeah or baja france yeah don't
place gusting
um i don't know carry around a gun
yeah go to what's up what's a white
thing
go to home depot see if you get a job go
to the parking lot
they go why would i hire a white lady
i'm not planning a party
um i'm not i don't need a uh event
planner
um yeah there's yeah just put yourself
in stereotypical latinx situations
sometimes lit tanks feels very racist
and sometimes it doesn't yeah it's weird
but we're gonna go with it we're gonna
go with it we're gonna ride it i
actually knew it
i didn't want to say 41 year old the
tanks because it in that joke
the first part of it was so racist i
didn't want to double down
don't ruin lieutenants yeah i know i
don't i won't and i and i won't
i don't and i won't uh
yes put yourself in
you know go to
again i'm only just gonna get more
racist yeah i know it's after two hours
you know how we get after two hours yeah
we can't even it's not even clever
racism it's just
a clan meeting level
bianca yes we don't have to take this
[ __ ]
and we're not gonna okay
have a great week [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
give it to me